Australian Neurodivergent Parents Association,
the AMPA has made history as the first
association run by and for neurodivergent parents
and those with psychosocial disabilities.
A MPA seeks to fill a gap in the community by
representing and addressing critical
needs for this parent demographic.
C, according to a MPA's president
Sarah Langston,
support for neurodivergent parents
is almost non existent
and discriminatory attitudes are systemic
with state and federal governments continuing
to fail neurodivergent parents
as demonstrating
evidence given through the Disability Royal Commission.
D, the Disability Royal Commission
released a report in July 23
that examined disabled parents experiences of child
protective services
and made 27 recommendations for change.
Parents with psychosocial disabilities
were identified as the key group whose children
are over represented in the out of home care system
in every state.
And it was highlighted that neurodivergent
parents are likely included in this group,
but there is insufficient data to distinguish them.
Also highlighted and e,
there are evident gaps in current
decision making and policy making mechanisms
which too often
leave out or misrepresent the experiences
and voices of neurodivergent parents.
And a MPA seeks to fill this gap
by fighting for genuine consultation and representation.
And 2, that this house commends the work and creation of
a MPA is the first Australian association
run entirely by and for neurodivergent parents.